the United States to the United Kingdom
Kiev to Kuala lumper Montenegro
Switzerland and now The Hague the list
of the G I use global operations is long
brazen and exposed on the 10th of April
for Russian GRU officers arrived at
Amsterdam's Schiphol Airport offer
flight from Moscow the four had traveled
on diplomatic passports two of those
parcels had almost identical numbers the
following day the 11th of April they
rented this car by then
Dutch intelligence was on to them at the
same time the OPCW based in The Hague
was investigating the Nava choc
poisoning on the scribbles and the
chemical attack in the Syrian town of
Duma the OPCW was the Russians target on
Friday the 13th of April three days
after they arrived Dutch security forces
stepped in they found specialist
equipment in the boot equipment used for
hacking into a Wi-Fi network the antenna
hidden under a coat was pointing
directly at the OPCW building the four
Russian spies were confronted and
escorted out of the country what was
their reaction when they were caught
they were quiet do they say anything do
they go quiet I'm not going to reveal
what
they were very quiet and you immediate
sorted them out of the country one of
the Russians had a taxi receipt from the
road outside the GRU headquarters to
Moscow Sheremetyevo Airport dated 10th
of April the same day they flew to
Amsterdam a laptop seized from the
suspects near the OPCW was found to have
been used in Switzerland and Malaysia as
well data showed that it was used in
Lausanne where it was linked to the
hacking of the world anti-doping agency
which exposed doping by Russian athletes
in Malaysia it had been directed at the
investigation into the downing of
Malaysia flight mh17 in 2014 that was
blamed on the Russians the GRU has
tended to focus on state institutions or
sovereign countries but by trying to
hack into the OPCW they were targeting
an international organization and they
were doing it because the OPCW was
investigating Russia and what had gone
on in Solsbury if they think they can
get away with floating in international
law trying to destabilize the way
democracies go about their business
sending agents in to use chemical
weapons on British soil for the first
time in our history if they think that
we're just going to lie down and accept
that they're wrong and there will be
consequences and they will regret doing
this a few hours after the revelations
in The Hague the US Department of
Justice announced indictments against
seven Russians it is evident from the
allegations in today's indictment that
the defendants believed that they could
use their anonymity to act with impunity
in their own countries and on the
territories of other sovereign nations
the Russian government has continued to
brush off the accusations and dismiss
them as nonsense who comes up with all
this I'd like to look at these people
you know it's just undignified for the
country which pretends to play one of
the leading roles in the world the new
tactic by London Washington and their
allies seems to be to expose the GRU and
its activities the West has been hitting
back in private but now also in public
alistair bungle Sky News the
cake